luna the fastest easiest way to buy bitcoin if
you're just getting into crypto it's the perfect
place to start hey guys and welcome back to my
show it's 10 p.m here so i am pushing through
we're keeping up the energy and it's gonna be
really great have a really interesting guest
before we bring on my amazing guest um this is
powered by icon plus as usual so a really quick
news announcement for you so this week icon
has announced its btp working group which will
fulfill icon's vision of becoming the go-to
interoperability blockchain and crypto by
the end of 2021 so lots of competition for this
spot at the moment so that's going to be really
interesting to see how it plays out now this is
um sponsored by blockbuy you can actually get up
to 250 if you sign up i use them you can also
get up to i think it's about 8.6 interest they
might change those i can't remember but they're
really cool i use them so i'd recommend them
um so joining me today is a really cool guest
somebody that i've only recently gotten to know
from the other side of the crypto community
it is crypto eddie what's up how are you doing
hey hey leia nice to see you hey how are you
thank you for inviting me onto your channel i'm
i'm great you know we are on opposite ends
of the world so for me it's a little after
seven in the morning so i feel like yes i'm up
early and it's going to be a very productive day
good i love that i think it's insane that we are
on opposite ends of the world right now because
i'm telling my friends that i've got a show and
it's 10 p.m at night and they think i'm absolutely
nuts and i said i'm speaking to somebody all
the way in japan and they think it's crazy
that we can do this in the community yeah there's
really no time in crypto at all in in terms of uh
geographic location zero zero yeah it's insane
and that's i think that was actually one of
the first things that hit me when i joined this
space i it's like a saturday night for me once
and i remember somebody was just messaging me
like trying to book in interviews and work and
i'm like what is happening right now it's the
weekend and it's you know midnight but you know
it's uh it's the time for someone somewhere
there is there is no weekend anymore is
what i've learned and you lose track of
days you don't even know which day it is
and the other thing too which is maybe maybe it's
just me but you hear the the people that do ta
yeah and they say the daily clothes well we
gotta hit the daily clothes i'm like oh wait
i still don't get that at all and i under
i understand what they're saying but really
it doesn't apply anymore crypto is 24 7. so
they're in and it's in it's uh you know i'm
17 hours ahead of most of the world so there
is no daily clothes anymore i don't get it
no you're absolutely right it's literally not but
i actually have fun with that sometimes because
like when bitcoin is like reaching you highs
or something like i can sort of say it happened
today and everyone's like no it happened yesterday
and i'm just sort of i like to play with it um but
i've got an interesting plan for us right now and
for our viewers so usually i keep things quite um
structured um even though it's probably nicer when
it's more chilled but it's just the way i mean
things quite structured but i'm gonna go totally
unfiltered and i've asked you to bring two topics
and i've brought two topics now i'll kick this off
um because i have a really interesting one which
i think everybody is going to really enjoy and
i think you and i might be a little bit aligned
on this um so usually i wouldn't talk about this
but i'm going to take it from a different angle
so i'm going to forgive me for saying these words
because it's just not like me but i'm going to
talk about women and crypto oh yeah no yeah i hate
i hate i hate it i don't know very often but it
but but maybe sometimes we should yeah yeah well
hang on before you get there see my angle first
see my angle okay so women in crypto women in
industries women in is sort of a term that we just
see thrown around all the time now i don't know if
i should get into this at 10 pm i've got to make
sure i articulate myself correctly um as to not
offend anyone um but i want to talk about it and
i really want to get your opinion on that kind
of stance and whether firstly you know we need
women in you know do we really need women in i'll
start with that what are your thoughts on that
well we need more people and so the if you're
gonna separate men from women the women are still
underrepresented up you know they're
just not represented like the men are so
um i guess we don't need them because of the
differences in in the way they think or the or the
way they they approach life i don't think that's
why we need them but i think that we need them
in to make sure that they are inclusive i feel
bad that that many of them are missing out
especially those that possibly don't have a
partner who has brought them into the space
because i understand some women are involved
but just not engaging with uh conversations on
twitter or what have you but they're not missing
out because they've got someone else that's that's
uh in the space some way somehow but what i feel
bad for are the women who are not don't have any
exposure to crypto that's that's that's horrible
and so that just again adds to the separation
of the haves and the haves have nots and and
that worries me that women are missing out
on one of the greatest transfers of wealth
that we're going to see in a very long time and
it's going to occur and it has occurred actually
it has occurred already and look how many people
have missed out so that worries me so i guess
the simple one line yes no answer to your uh
question is yes we do but it's not because we're
we're different it's because i don't want women
to miss out yeah i think there's two parts there
so i tend to agree with you when we talk about
i don't necessarily think women bring anything
different just because they're women i i really
don't i think you know people are so diverse and
so complex that their value goes far beyond their
gender um i'm never offended when knowing that
there's more men in the space i think that it's
sort of just natural and i get a bit frustrated
seeing people push women down paths which i think
from a biological standpoint they're sort of
let's you know generically less interested in
but in terms of giving women exposure i think
it's a really interesting point so somebody was
talking about gun rights to me and they said gun
rights are a woman's right and i thought that was
really fascinating um whether your programs or not
whatever but i thought that was really fascinating
just because i could sort of understand that you
know in terms of protecting women empowering women
and i sort of feel a similar way to crypto
because of what you're saying in terms of that
that wealth and that that that generational
wealth and that that kind of move um because i
think one of the things that is so important
for women is i hate seeing women trapped
because they don't have um they don't have wealth
and then they're not able to let's say you know do
what they want pick a man that they want because
they feel like they have to follow you know wealth
or money or whatever it is so i guess you know it
financially empowers women so from that standpoint
i like it yeah the last thing you want to see is
people not make decisions to improve their life
in terms of being happy uh because financially
they can't afford to and so that is that's that's
and that happens typically more often with women
especially those women who have children because
they are really driven to be a caretaker and
so they their energy is is just wiped out in
terms of time and focus and they really you know
it's it's it's just that much more difficult so
yeah it's it's in how and i've never really
approached like how am i going to change that
because i don't believe that that should be
something i try to do i just try to do my own
thing and actually my world is i feel
it's genderless to be honest with you
okay i i don't even remember half the time
because i'm i'm actually i've been in this
space in the working world for years and years and
years and years and it's always always the field
that i have been in has always been predominantly
male i mean it's been always 80 percent
and or more and so i i guess i just don't think i
don't think in terms of gender believe it or not
i really don't but i think that it's really
a shame if if the women are left out yeah
and yeah the women that are following me
by the way i i you know i i do do take
notice and they are older and i don't
know if that's just because i'm older
or if it's just because they have matured in
their in their line of investments you know
but it's i don't have a lot of young when i'm
talking young i mean you know we we all know
when we have a youtube channel that google breaks
down our analytics for us on our back side so we
see a lot it's not like we're guessing we actually
see the numbers that come and we see that you know
the the 20s and the 30s and the 40s and the 50s
and the 60s they break it down for us right i
i don't know about you but what is your percentage
of women have you looked lately on your analytics
where are you absolutely tiny it's tiny it's
mainly men and and i'm really okay with that
i'm beyond okay with it because i like i said
i'm never offended by it and there's this huge
push to bring more women in and i just to
put it bluntly i don't think it's that deep
you know as they say like i don't think it's
that dramatic um i think like we're talking about
before i think it's amazing to empower people give
them financial freedom um and you know like you
were saying women sometimes have a harder time you
know naturally taking on the role of the caretaker
for their kids and whatever and so you know
having that that kind of passive income is
so liberating um and amazing um but i just i get
so frustrated and you know here's a funny thing
as well i think i'm quite vocal about it i think
i'm quite vocal about my stance on it and i get
people reaching out to me saying hey we should
work together we you know we need more women in
i love your content and i'm like i'm like don't
try and connect with me no i run from that i run
it's really rare that that you and i have
connected now the second time because
it's just it's just super rare
because i don't do it because
i have an agenda to bring in more women or
that i i just don't do it it's just not my
in fact i even get a little i even get
a little uh don't do that when i see the
oh you know the most you see the list coming
from media that says the most influential women
in crypto or the or the uh you know i just was
like why do we have to why do we have to do that
why well here's a dilemma here's a dilemma
somebody actually um featured me in an article as
a woman in and you know like i'm a nice person and
i appreciate that i thought that was really kind
so i was like i was like do i retweet or do i not
do i retweet or do i ignore i was like right now i
have to like i retweeted it because you know it
was nice to be included so i was like whatever
yeah i mean i was invited to participate
in the binance finance has a has a yeah
yeah you probably know about it i can't do it
because i i still am um a u.s citizen and so
i'm i'm unable to participate in that group but
i even have trouble with that you know it's like
i understand what they're trying to do but it
i think in in at the end of the day it just
provides more division and more
separation and that's what i don't like
yeah i totally agree with you and i think this
idea is exactly the same when it comes to race
and obviously i'm not black so i find it
really hard to i feel a bit uncomfortable
talking about this but i as a woman i do feel like
it's the exact same idea just you can literally
just follow through the ideology in that it's
almost i find it almost insulting and almost
patronizing to be chosen based on my gender
and saying like okay let's do something nice
for the ladies it's like no no that's actually
insulting that you think that we need something
nice like just if you really want to if you want
equality then treat me as an equal don't make a
nice little cute um you know little show i was
like nah it's okay like i can make my own show
you know what i mean and yeah i mean here's
an interesting one and then then we'll move
on top and then we'll move on to the topics um
a lot of people talk about nature versus nature
and a lot of people will say well no women
would be more interested if it wasn't for social
programming you know like men are given bob the
builder um wait do you you're not bob the builder
is or is that a british thing is it an icon that
he's kind of a muscled out guy and real madrid
i don't know it's funny i just realized it was
british that's so funny um it's it's like like an
action man you know action man yeah oh you know
okay good i'm just making sure um okay yeah so
it's like an action man it's basically encouraging
boys at a young age you know like you're bob the
builder you build you're strong and then women
get like dolls and babies and we get like the
processor barbie yes i'm sorry yeah i i see okay
so is it an action figure that's sold in the uk
no bob the builder is um a tv show actually um
but it's a bit bit like they'd sell the merch
and you know boys would be i'm bob the
builder you know it's not like it's not like
chloe it's probably chloe the cleaner not chloe
there or chloe the chef not chloe the builder
which is also fine so my question is sorry my
question is is it nature versus nurture or is
this actual like programming from a young age
which has then made us choose different things
well i think it's a little of both i think
it's a little both i think we're definitely
a you know product of our environment for
sure and a product of how we get pushed
into certain roles but i also think there's
a there's there is something to be said about
you are you know you're you're born
that way so i think it's a little
both i don't think it's so easy it's
it's much more complex than that
i totally agree with you i do think it's a bit
of both um but what i can say is i have two older
brothers and so when i was younger i definitely
went through a phase of wearing boy clothes and
i didn't i don't play with barbies i play with
action man you know i i watch wrestling and all
that stuff because my brothers were interested
in that but as i got older and i actually
became into myself i started to become far more
feminine because you can't really fight biology
yeah that's where you are who you are and then
yeah and then the other thing i think sometimes
girls do go through that period where they try to
uh compete with boys to almost just have you know
proving to yourself that you can do it i remember
playing flag football with the boys i hated
the football game but i wanted to play the flag
football because i wanted to show the guys i can
you know i can be as well as they can so uh yeah
i just think it's so much more complex than than
i but i but i wish we paid less attention
to it is what i guess i'm saying
which is why i don't like the i don't like the
list i don't like the campaigns i don't like
the narrative behind it i don't even like when
i get on the backside of twitter and i'm in a
you know we have sometimes we have backside
twitter groups right and um if you make yourself
known you'll hear comments like oh clean up the
language we've got a lady in here and i'm thinking
to myself you should hear me think i'm terrible so
that almost then takes away my right to be able to
to use whatever language i want to use because
it's considered that it has to be cleaned up
because i'm because you know oh we got a woman
in the house we got to clean up the language
i just all of that just drives me crazy yeah i'm
totally with you and i think when it comes to
kind of these differences overall the more we talk
about it and the more we make a big thing about it
the more we perpetuate it i mean i mean we can
just look at like america is just so funny as
an example i mean they literally have black only
spaces to make to to make it like a safe space
yes like in parts of college campuses yeah to make
it like a safe space um which is which is which is
literally taking you back to the 60s it's the same
result different intentions but the same result
and we're still segregating we're still you know
it's still an issue and i think kind of like the
only way to get over is just not talk about it
just to move forward basically um well i don't
know why you would do that so so if you had a
space take take anything else out let's say you
are um asian and you have an asian faith a safe
asian space and then what happens if then you end
up marrying somebody who is completely you're
a traitor yeah and then and then your child
is is automatically if you if you promote
that separate spaces and if you have children
then your child is actually out there's no there's
no there's no space you know so i i don't i don't
understand why people would support that i
don't understand it i'm with you and i think
the biggest issues that um people who are um mixed
race find they don't know where they belong um
i mean my cousins are actually mixed race
and i know that i know that and and they're
mixed with religion and it's a lot and i know
that they're beautiful and everything they're
just growing up i think they definitely weren't
sure where they belonged because they didn't
belong there but they didn't belong there and
it's a shame um and it and it's crazy so i think
it's an interesting topic and i think you know we
massively agree which was really cool when i sort
of noticed you're like liking some of those things
i wrote and i was like ooh we're on the same page
i like that um but i asked you to bring a topic
so hit me with it so i just looked this morning
i had one actually last night that i had in mind
and then i re-read that you said bring two so i
had to think of another one and that one i'm gonna
bring up now and i looked on the you have the most
interesting tweets lately i mean your tweets the
style of your tweets i'm usually way too wordy
i'm always trying to put way too much into the
space and you've got it down to where you are
you are just pin pointing your point in a probably
less than six or seven words it's a real i can't
do it so i really admire and and you're always
just really for me at least you're hitting
you're hitting very hot points of topics
for discussion and for critical thought
and the one that you put recently was what's the
worst financial decision you made and what's the
best financial decision you made and when you
actually have to ask yourself that wow that's a
that's a big one to talk to think about and it
wasn't so easy for me to do it because i think
you start to look at like maybe something
that you bought that required maintenance
for example like now that i live in in tokyo
i don't have to own a car and so i think gosh
owning a car was one of the worst financial
decisions i ever made because of the maintenance
and of the insurance and of the gas and everything
i mean you know so but what i really think
was the worst financial decision i have made many
times in my life is to align yourself or to spend
time on people who are very difficult to maintain
a friendship with and what i mean difficult
is that they they grab your focus away from
what you're really trying to focus on they
suck you full of ener you know your energy because
you're always trying to make them happy you know
it's the people who are always complaining about
something or they're they're always having some
drama in their life and eventually you realize
that that's the way they are on a daily basis
and they're depriving you of i think a lot of
happiness and so the worst decision financially
is to remain friends with those people and spend
time in and the best decision and it's the hardest
is to move on it's really brutal but
you have to really choose who you
who you spend your valuable
time with and on so that yeah
no i think it's brilliant um you are i say
this every single day you are absolutely a
product of i think at least what did they say
the five people you spend your time with um
and i think and i was talking to somebody earlier
i think when you're in this space or you know when
you when you're ambitious or you have a dream or
whatever it is or you know you think for yourself
or you want to do things a bit differently it
can be a bit of a lonely path to take um because
not everybody sees the world the way you see it
um even right now politically you know we're so
divided you know the conversation we just had is
a conversation that i probably couldn't have with
a lot of my friends um they would you know they'd
be very like obviously we need women in you know
it's on a very surface level
you can't really be like but why
um so i i'm i'm definitely with you and i think
that's actually hard though isn't it because you
have to i was about to i was like would you rather
be alone or surrounded by the wrong people right
how do you feel about that oh i'm
totally i guess i'm one of those people
i am completely comfortable with being alone i'm
the type of person i can go to dinner by myself
you know can you do it it's easy for me actually
yeah i mean i've done a lot of lunches by myself
because i've lived in a lot of foreign cities on
my own so i've done a lot of like wine like you
know imagine like the french style like wine and
like a vogue you know posh cigarette the way they
you know i tried that one out and that was um but
yeah i mean i i'm with you i love my own space
i'm actually moving house i'm moving countries
but um i was trying to decide whether to live
with somebody or whether to not live with somebody
and i was about to choose to live with this girl
there's this terrace it's huge you know it's
amazing i literally panicked i panicked so much
because i feel like people's energy rubs off on me
really easy really easily um and i just i like who
i am and i just want to like protect my energy
and so i'm really conscious of being with other
people um because i just i really like to spread
out and like you know the way i'm doing like this
with my arms like i just like want to i can't even
verbalize what i'm trying to say i like to express
myself and i i would worry living with someone
that um that i couldn't yeah it's added stress
it's like do you take a vacation alone or you
take a vacation with someone and i i i can do both
but i have just as much fun going alone you
know it's easier it's easier it's just easier
it is you don't have to answer to anyone you
can go for dinner when you want to go for dinner
you can stay out as long as you want to stay out
you know you don't have to think about anyone i
mean like i was saying when i was thinking about
living with someone what if i want to have a bunch
of friends over like i'm very social you know get
everybody over have a big barbecue i'd hate to ask
someone for permission right hate it yeah so so
i i imagine you decided to go go to you know live
alone and you're gonna move out of the country
while you're going to a new country have you ever
lived in this country before that you've chosen
no i've never lived there i've been a bunch of
times on holiday but i've never lived there but
to be honest like i just i just totally need it
i just i'm in the uk right now and it's too cold
for me um the cold makes my heart cold um so yeah
so yeah it'll be it'll be really good um but i i'm
totally with you i think you know you have to be
so careful you surround your who you surround
yourself with and sometimes it means walking a
lonely uh path but it is what it is isn't it yeah
i guess i just don't see it as the lonely path
yeah i just don't see it that way i just see
it as uh i'm tired of trying to compromise and
set my you know set my life back
uh based on trying to take care and
you know help people who can't be helped you
know i've you you try but there are some people
who just choose to go to that you know unhappy
lots of drama always have a problem and and then
it takes your time and that's what the financial
part that's what i'm saying is that finance
financial financial success is based on how much
time you have for us right now in crypto time is
really really important because we have to do a
lot of research and if you don't have that time
to devote to the space to make good decisions well
then you're going to get financially burned so
that's that's why i see the connection of
opportunity costs of uh spending time with
shitty people there you go it is it's out you're
yeah you're absolutely right um you know i think
it it it's just especially you know even when
you're trying to bring people into crypto and you
sort of say to them trust me you know you really
want to do this you really want to get this and
having to go over the same thing and the same
thing in the same thing and some people just
don't want to some people don't want to learn some
people don't want to take risks some people just
don't want to hear it um you know i've had that
so many times when i'm trying to help people with
their career like i think social media is just
so important as we've seen and um you know i know
people who are trying to do this and trying to
do that and i'm like please leverage social media
there's only so many times i can say it and then
then you know the opportunity cost kicks in and
it's like okay i gotta get back to work yeah
right yeah you will it's that whole you can lead
a horse to water but you can't make it drink so
i don't even do the leading to the water anymore
you have absolutely had enough i love that but
speaking of bringing new people in um this was
another topic i wanted to chat to you about we
can go briefly over this one to be honest but
um nfts i really wanted to get your opinion
on it because they're really hot um i think
two minutes ago i read so nobody quote me on
this okay i saw on bloomberg maybe new york
new york times or new york post i don't know
i'm not american um they put out an article
about nfts and then they made it into an nft
so so like this thing is going mainstream
um i wondered what your thoughts
were on it do you think it's a bubble
or do you think um you know there's actual
useful technology here beyond the bubble
i think a couple of things because i have a
background in high-resolution digital images that
uh from a world of art publishing and
what i'm seeing in a lot of these nfts is
the violations of intellectual property
sometimes and many times you're going
to see images that that person doesn't have
the right to use especially when you use it
in the form of making money on it and so nobody's
clearing the rights on these images now people
totally that was all his work he made one image
every day by himself five thousand days in a row
no problem but if you go and go through wearable
or if you go through uh open c you can see the use
of many many images like in montages and
collages and and they the people who are
selling that don't have the rights they have not
cleared the rights with either there are rules
in in the world of how long an image belongs
to the artist and france has actually defined
for us in this world up to 70 years and then if
that artist dies the family has the rights to
continue a foundation to protect the rights
of that artist and so you see a lot of great
artists that were in the turn of the century
or um they haven't fallen into public domain
because they still have the rights being
maintained by by a family foundation so that's
one thing i see and that hasn't blown up yet and i
know that there are a lot of intellectual property
attorneys out there that are getting contacted and
and i think you're going to see a lot of lawsuits
so that's that's one point that i have that i
think the people who are not in the space of
images you know this is the first time that
the mass masses have been brought in to buy
images and they don't understand intellectual
property rights okay so that's one second
thing is i think that the the nfts as they are
today are not going to be the nfts that we see
a year or two or three or four download i
think it's going to evolve and it's going to be
for example i think that technology is
going to allow us to to actually create
nfts that have technology in them that
include more than just maybe an audio file
but but more data is going to be you
know it's going to go to a next level
so that if you wanted to for example cherry
blossom season right now and i take a picture of a
really beautiful blossom but what i want to do
is i also want to embed the surrounding audio for
that so that somebody can say oh my gosh i've got
this image of the you know in terms of a uh let's
say a short video but in addition to that short
video i can hear the audio of people walking uh
and talking and so you've got these conversations
that are going and i just think that the the whole
experience of an nft is going to be way way more
than just a static image or a short video yeah i
think it's going to totally change i don't think
it has sustainability with the way it is right now
yeah i think so going back to your first point
about regulation i think that one's really
interesting because i've seen um you know people's
tweets being minted as nfts and sold um surely
there has to be some issues regarding intellectual
property i mean if somebody took one of my tweets
don't do anyone watching you know i'd be a little
bit frustrated so i'm sure there's some issues
surrounding that i don't know which jurisdiction
gets involved i don't know how it works yeah new
laws will be created because this is a space that
is new so you're you're going to have attorneys
that actually take it to the courts and then there
will be rulings and then it'll be like you can't
ever take anybody's tweet you can't ever take
anybody's um image without their permission or
you have to license it you know yeah all those
all those new rules and laws will be formed
out of this yeah no oh absolutely and we're
already seeing that happen crypto now in general
right um but what the way i look at it is okay
so i think like the nft digital art situation
is a bubble in my opinion i think there's value
but i think it's a bubble in that right now
it's just blowing up but the idea that you
can verify something i think is fantastic
yeah so maybe i'm looking at this like really in
a 2d kind of way but i've said this before but i
really look at the value of nfts coming from like
physical things like if you have a rolex watch or
a handbag or like you design a product and then
you can you know actually verify and know um you
know whether it's real or not because fakes are
getting so um they're getting so advanced to the
point where they're not even a fake they just came
out of different factories but basically yes the
same factory but different uh different vans so
the supply chain is just different um somewhere
on that chain right so i think that's gonna
be really interesting um and you know talking
about advancing it i also think you know house
deeds um i think i saw somebody sent me today um
let me get it on my phone actually i can get it up
somebody told me that um an nft of a digital house
has just been has gone up let me see if i can
find it here we go so mars house the world's
first nft backed virtual home sold for more than
317 000 pounds a virtual home that you can't even
live in it's gimmicky it's it's not the
bubble though is that the bubble yeah i mean
i mean it's fun for people to be a part
of that because and i think and i think
also the people who are buying at
these crazy prices it's also like
again i'm just going to take you back to a
situation in japan at the first of the year always
at new year they auction off a big tuna and that
tuna is like kind of setting the precedence for
the market for the new year and it it'll sell
for like unbelievable amount of money like you
know like a million dollars for a blue
tuna and yeah and the guy who oh i think
yeah can you hear me yes yeah is it me or is
it you you're you're perfect you're not lagging
you're not lagging can you hear me oh
there we go i think we're back yeah you
were perfect i can't hear you can you hear me
yes you can hear me yes okay i can't hear you
maybe it's me bear with me one sec let's have
a look audio i didn't mute myself mike speakers
testing i don't know can you guys let us
know in the comments if who you can hear
guys let us know if you can hear me because
arie i can't hear you eddie i can't do it
i you're fine and i don't show
muted i don't know why you and me
oh you can hear both of us that's cool they can
hear both of us but i'm the only one that can't
hear oh i can hear you now i can hear you now
okay okay wait no it's cut out let's cut out let
me take these out okay i can hear you okay i think
i know what it is there we go yeah maybe it's my
my rubbish airpods i actually dropped them on the
on the floor before before we started so there we
go i'm sorry i missed what you were saying we were
talking about the house and how that's the bubble
yeah and so i think that um the people who
are buying these at crazy prices are doing
it for marketing in my opinion they're
bringing attention to themselves and then
if they can use it as a line item to write
off uh it's just becomes a a marketing expense
you know you can you can turn that purchase
into a marketing expense that you you can
justify oh i purchased this to give myself
some exposure because i needed to have um
you know a a window to advertise myself my product
or whatever so i think some of these prices are
being driven by just people who have money that
want to bring attention to themselves and it's a
form of marketing so that's that's where i think
some of these high prices are coming from yeah
i mean justin sun is the perfect example of that
what did justify he he didn't he like offer well
firstly he was he's always putting like millions
down i can't remember how much he put he offered
on the people thing maybe he put down like a few
million um and then he you know the warren buffett
thing a few a few years ago he's always putting
down millions um but what's your final topic
tell me what's the final topic um i want to talk
about micro excellence have you heard i have not
so i didn't really know this term either and
it is a term that a lot of athletes have used
in their training and you know really easily to
be understood is that it's about just improving
like a one percent from the day prior to bring
your excellence up to a level where you are
going to just kill it and what the these uh
trainers have learned is that if you apply this
micro excellence in your life for even just
the simplest things that the tasks that you
do every day i'm talking about tasks like like
laundry or task like cleaning or whatever it's
the same it the same outcome applies so it's not
about what you have accomplished it's all about
how much have you improved on a day to day by day
basis and so you know i think as content creators
i don't know about you but but it's a challenge to
keep your life in balance um for some of the jobs
or some of the things that you have to do that uh
you know i just give you one example because you
can you can tie it to something that is as trivial
as and i'm going to give you a real example
so being a content creator has taken me away from
maintaining a garden okay okay and i'm really sad
about that because i really really love to take
care of of the plants and the flowers i just want
you can't do both ah see that's that balance of
time so i um unfortunately i i you know everybody
says well you have it's your choice you're not
exercising why not it's your choice you can do it
but it it's life is always about trying to find
that balance so i've got it i've got a balcony
that's full of old potted plants that have died oh
that i know it's terrible and then when you see it
and you think to yourself oh my gosh this is going
to take me all day if not two days to clean up
so instead of trying to do it all
at once you just every day attack it
like maybe just one pot i'm just going to take one
pot today and then you dump out the dirt and then
that pot goes into either storage or whatever
whatever it is you want to do with it
and then the next day okay let's let's do
one percent better than i did yesterday
and the concept is is that when you
take those jobs that you just keep
putting off the simple tasks of of just
maintaining your life so that it has balance
and you can apply it to your exercise your
food you know how you see some people they say
i really don't like vegetables but i'll but
i'll have one bite of a vegetable today and then
next day i'll have two bites and you know it's the
same sort of thing but what i found is that the
concept of this my you know this micro excellence
concept of just improving your day by one percent
every day really does work really does work yeah i
had no idea that it was called micro excellence is
that we said it was that's what the athletes call
it yeah it's really interesting i totally agree
it's not something that i consciously thought
about um but i'm with you because just in general
when you want to achieve something sometimes it
can be so daunting and it's like looking at like
these really big steps you know these huge steps
that you have to climb which are you know in front
of you but if you just take okay well i just have
to do a small step we can do a small step you know
we go to sleep again we breath so then we eat then
the next day i can do another small step you know
so i guess it is just it's just small steps but
i totally agree with you in terms of you know
creating content and having to find that balance
um and uh there's always i don't know where the
saying comes from i'm too sleepy at this point
to remember but there's a saying uh was uh you're
only as good as your last performance or whatever
it is you know so i'm always like i'm terrible i'm
always like well i'm only as good as my last video
or my last tip top you know if one tic top got
half a million views but the only uh that one got
to 2 000 i'm like well i'm only worth 2 000 views
you have to you have to find that balance
and what i would say though is everything
that we've had with this pandemic has just thrown
balance just right off you know it's you know the
uk is still in lockdown i've been in lockdown
since december and um which has been insane
um and there is no balance so why you know
why am i working at night well because i
you know number one i like it but also
number two i don't have anywhere to go
so you know that totally throws that balance off
but and then it shows you how much you need that
balance and i think that's something
that i'm kind of trying to figure out
well what like what's my plant pot what's
my garden right like what do i want to ditch
that i can't that i can't do because you just
can't do everything and it's really figuring out
what what what don't i need and what do
i need to prioritize basically isn't it
yeah the the the situation that everybody's
in in this world right now has really
proven to well sure i think everyone's been
quite resilient and and adapted pretty well
for working but i think people are working more
hours than they did when they used to go to
an office yeah because you you're able to
actually work all the time and people don't
respect the hours anymore of like you know
eight to five or yeah six or whatever so
i think that we we are out of our routine and i
think the new routines that everybody is in has
been a lot you know disruptive but at the same
time too i'm really happy that we have found
that we can work more from home yeah i think i
think this commuting business to uh and it's like
think about just the think about
the footprint that you make on
the environment for one for commuting
yeah and look at all the wasted time
and look at all who's getting rich on that
when when you are you are having to i mean
especially women are trying to always keep the
good look it and you know have have the right
clothes have the right makeup the time that it
takes to get yourself ready to go to the office
the commute time itself the cost of of of just you
know the pure cost and actually moving your body
from from one location to another you you lose at
least two hours out of your day you know i i just
don't i just don't think working in the office
was a good idea to begin with i'm so glad that
the world proved to themselves the business
can still happen without going to an office
now i understand if you're in commercial real
estate you know you're sitting on empty buildings
or people who are trying to get out of their
leases and i understand the impact in terms of
of real estate commercial real estate but i i
i'm just so glad that a lot of people proved
that we don't have to go into an office that's
crazy yeah i'm with you i think the commute is
the most revolting thing that's ever been invented
okay i'm really passionate about that i think
i obviously are from london so we know about how
the commute works you know people can't afford to
live in london so they live on the outskirts and
they have to travel an hour and a half in an hour
and a half out there's three hours of your day
so i used to do a job as a journalist in london
it took me an hour and a half to get in and then
i'd have a shoe so somebody that i'd have to film
the other side of london so like i'd rush into
work at like it took me an hour and a half to
get there and once i was there i had to rush all
the equipment to the other side of london rush
all the way back like oh my god like all day i'm
just rushing yeah quality of life like you know
especially in london i'm sure it's probably the
same in all these major cities in tokyo yeah you
leave before the sun rises and you're back home
after the sun has set that is not quality of life
right and and some of those people doing the
commutes on the trains here they have to stand the
entire way can you you can't even get a seat okay
is it expensive in tokyo oh yeah it it it goes
back and forth of being one of the most expensive
cities to live in but if you're really you know
just i guess depends on which neighborhood you
want to be in and how large of a space you want
uh but if you do get a good neighborhood and and
a large space yeah it's one of the most expensive
cities in in the world i mean people always people
always tell me oh well look at the prices in
in san francisco or look at the places in in uh
another expensive cities like hong kong singapore
is very expensive uh you know hawaii is very
expensive also norway is very expensive yeah so
i know there's there's there's expensive cities
all over but tokyo is pretty expensive but you
can live cheap here it's just can you're just not
going to live in a convenient place and you're not
going to live in a big place you're going to live
in a in a really tiny place i think what annoys
me is kind of um the the lie that i told that
we need to live in a city in order to do well
so when i was younger i used to go on holidays to
let's say like beach towns or whatever and i when
i fall in love with the beach i fell in love with
the ocean and the weather and everything and i i'd
want to stay there and then i'd say to myself
well you know nothing successful happens here
or you can't be successful living here you have to
live in a city and that's just absolutely rubbish
um you know and i think we're going to see a
massive exodus from these really expensive cities
in the next decade um so yeah i think that's gonna
be fascinating they're already people are already
you know moving out of big cities and actually
they're moving out of states poor california is
losing tons and tons of people yeah well i think
that's what happens when i won't get into it but
i'm not surprised it's a pretty liberal state and
unfortunately the homelessness there is terrible
i mean my friends were telling me when they go to
san francisco i mean i've not been i don't know i
hear when you go to san fran apparently there are
people just like shooting up on the streets and
you know it's just not worth all that money
yeah in that kind of environment i don't know
the homeless camps in la have gotten really
um unbelievable you know it's really it's so
interesting they used to have uh some of the
parks used to have when i first arrived here
homeless communities where they actually got the
mail delivered to their to their yeah it's not
anything it was unbelievable but uh
then there was kind of a change in um
who came into to the local government power and
they moved them all out and nike came in and built
a skateboard park and where they used to live
and and it's just now yeah totally changed but
um yeah california is really especially southern
california is really really dealing with that
that's a that's a that's a whole nother really
complex issue yeah i think the move that i'm
seeing everybody make down to texas down to
florida is just insane um i'm following it but
um sure the people down in austin too are like oh
my god get these californians out of here oh yeah
i hear that i hear you have democrats moving down
to republican states voting for the same policies
that were implemented up there so yeah i'll see
how that plays out it'll be interesting but eddie
i want to thank you so much for coming on it's
been so good chatting to you being so excited to
do this um because i just think we have a lot in
common i really like your work i love your energy
i love what you do on youtube you built something
so incredible on there so honestly well done i'm
following and i really enjoy it where can people
get hold of you follow you find out your work
yeah i i really um i wanted to say though
before that is that i really want to thank
you for the most of the more important thing
leia is that um not so much should we have
more women in this space what i really really
think and i this i feel very passionate about
is that yeah it's totally okay to be a part of
two different communities right and and and i i
i'm gonna love you no matter what community you
align yourself with but i think what's really
really important and i want to thank you for
that is having this cross-communication where
where just because we are into different projects
um actually i'm into your project it's just
it's not the only project that i pay attention
to so that's why i have a crypto eddy channel
and it's e-r-i and and i have
been covering this space in a
fairly wide sense i'm i'm not i'm not you
know covering all the balls but maybe the top
within the top 50 projects that are out there
that have real utility and that's what i'm
paying attention to and then um yeah i'm i'm on
twitter too of course because those two kind of
go hand in hand yeah absolutely i think all this
tribalism in my opinion is just [ __ ] um i don't
i don't really think i fit in in any community
um i guess you could say i'm a bitcoiner but
the maxis don't like me anyway so you know that's
that um so because i i'm interested enough to i'm
interested i'm open-minded i'm interested like you
know and that's what it is um but yeah to me look
if people are cool and you can have a good chat
then i'm happy to have a good chat no matter what
coins you're holding so thank you so much for
coming on and um i want to thank everybody for
watching and don't forget to tune in next thursday
for another fabulous guest see you later bye